here's what would happen if you stopped
drinking water
giving up water is a death sentence a
slow painful death sentence now the
first few hours would be easy because
your thirst would be minimal but over
the next two days your heart rate would
need to increase rapidly to maintain
normal oxygen levels your body would be
fighting to stay alive by day three
you'd have lost four percent of your
body weight and your blood would become
so thick and concentrated that your skin
would shrivel up like a raisin by day
four every move you made would have you
reeling in agony is the toxins building
up in your system would make your
muscles sensitive and inflamed you'd be
so dehydrated that your brain would
slowly be losing cognitive function on
day five your liver would be ready to
stop working entirely now if you checked
into a hospital at this point you'd
probably survive but with lifelong
damage to your body because